un vol entre dublin et londres la
semaine dernière une dizaine de
passagers seulement étaient à bord
certes un avion sillonne le ciel
complètement vide
et ce n'est pas une légende non c'est
une réalité présentement sur la planète
terre il y a plusieurs sociétés
aériennes qui sans forcer à cause des
directives qui ont été prises dans le
passé de faire voler leurs avions
c'est une réglementation européenne qui
exige que les compagnies fassent
atterrir au moins 80% des avions prévu
dans les aéroports sous peine de se voir
retirer ces créneaux payer parfois
plusieurs dizaines de millions d'euros
mais en ces temps de coronavirus la
fréquentation baisse
exemple le vol 890 d'air canada entre
toronto et rome bière moins de quarante
passagers sur les quelque 300 sièges du
boeing 787
les liaisons avec l'italie ont été
annulés aux gens il est évident qu'air
canada où quelques sociétés aériennes
que ça soit veulent diminuer la
fréquence de leurs voiles et d'aller
remplir de façon optimale et dans les
circonstances exceptionnelles
le ministre français de l'économie est
monté au créneau pour dénoncer une
absurdité
c'est mauvais pour l'environnement
mauvais pour l'économie ça n'a aucun
sens sont les règles absurdes sont
faites pour être modifiée et elles
seront effectivement modifié ou au moins
suspendu temporairement la commission
européenne va légiférer rapidement sur
ces questions de créneaux l'organisation
de l'aviation civile devrait peut-être
passer une loi automatique dans le futur
pour que les transporteurs aériens mais
port à se mettre à genoux pour demander
de suspendre cette loi-là du 80%
on prévoit pour l'instant que le
coronavirus pourrait leur faire perdre
entre 63 et 113 millions de dollars
ici mathieu prost radio canada
montréal